can I ask this one last question the
people who said during the campaign that
Hillary Clinton was the lesser of two
evils could we get the apology right now
yeah what why what is it are you serious
I'm serious that like Hillary Clinton
would have a cabinet with Betsy DeVos
and and [ __ ] Rick Perry my god she
wouldn't ever know a line but they
wouldn't have a Muslim and they wouldn't
be warming with everybody in the world
it wouldn't be sweet it wouldn't be
doing the show Russia are you crazy
bear hug it home down though there is no
Berlin but if there was I'll be [ __ ]
awesome
sorry why did we think about Hysterium
talk about 85% reward what you do a lot
of what I do fish you say she hasn't
done this he hasn't done that he's not
going to do all these things give him a
[ __ ] chance mate annual event my god
she let him kill the Jews on the first
day he worked up to it night that is the
exact that is the exact ridiculous
hysterical over the top nonsense it
pretty very freely mayor being like
lotta body then it would have taken you
insula very just like you just like that
you won the apprentice and you have a
famous friend mate that's all you're
[ __ ] right can I say one thing I know
you like tea leaves or you are using
your audience he does not raise you my
foot is something unpleasant and why
can I say this might be so bitter right
with me this might be the worst thing
that could happen and you all haven't
even considered this just suppose just
suppose that Donald Trump on these
horrible white men and the one black man
that's even worse than Carlton the home
that they made everything better would
not be awful yeah